anthony you came into this series
averaging basically
30 and nine against this denver team but
you one-upped yourself with 37 and 10
tonight
how have your teammates put you in a
position to succeed in this specific
matchup with denver
um he's telling me to be aggressive you
know you know they told me in order
for us to get to where we want to go you
know they're gonna have to lean on me
and
my job to come out and be aggressive
obviously the first
time i've been in this situation uh the
western conference finals so
it was new to me but you know once the
ball gets thrown up to start the game
and i'm ready to go um and i just try to
get to my spots take my time rely on my
defense
get out of transition and and you know
play the right way and
you know we did a good job defensively
you know and
we didn't do we haven't done anything
special you know we basically took court
took care of home court
uh but we have three more to go your
first trip to the western conference
finals you guys also accomplished
something new tonight you won a game one
something you didn't do yet in this
postseason how did you master those five
days off because you basically had four
or five days off in between each series
to maximize your effort tonight
um coach did a great job putting our
practice plan together
you know our schedule of still trying to
practice every other day
kind of scrimmage every other day they
stay in rhythm and
it benefited tonight you know looked
like we were still in rhythm still in
still in shape
still sharp on everything we had a
couple mishaps on defense but
um that happens you know you got two
guys like joe kitchen murray who's
who's talented offensively um they're
going to make shots
they're going to put us in situations
where you know the advantage is for them
but we got to keep fighting and
uh you know it was great for us tonight
congratulations on the win and your
first conference finals anthony thank
you we'll see you next time
all right what a performance tonight
anthony davis nuggets had a two-point
lead at the end of the first quarter
it was all lakers after that